voici à quoi ressemble un triomphe
politique
la joie des militants la fierté d'une
heure personne ne l'avait vu venir cette
victoire fracassante dans leurs rêves
les plus fous
les stratèges du parti espérait
remporter 35 sièges au québec
la réalité a dépassé le rêve 10h37
les résultats sont sans équivoque
majoritaire la soirée sera beaucoup plus
courte que prévue et pourtant les
conservateurs avaient cru pouvoir
neutraliser cet adversaire fils à papa
néophytes à la belle chevelure disaient
les pubs justin n'est pas prêt les
campagnes négatives
premièrement ne sert plus à rien disons
le ce sont des boomerangs qui reviennent
sur la tête de ceux qui les lancent
le parcours de justin trudeau est
atypique le garçon qui a grandi dans
l'ombre de pierre elliott s'est exilé
dans l'ouest quelques années loin des
feux de la rampe enseignants homme de
théâtre à ses ordres
dès qu'il s'est lancé en politique en
2008 l'étiquette de novices bien nul ne
l'a plus lâchée confondre les sceptiques
démentir cette image d'apprentis justin
trudeau ci prendra de façon non
traditionnels on le donnait perdant à
trois contre un avant le match de boxe
contre le sénateur conservateur patrick
brazeau a mangé des coûts il a su
essoufflé son adversaire et le bar a été
le point de départ le pense d'une
ascension est aussi la mise à jour d'une
personnalité qu'on lui connaissait peu
on le savait fils de bonne famille mais
mais on voit que dans le gentleman
cacher des beaux quartiers il peut y
avoir un voyou aussi est quelqu'un qui a
envie de se battre aux campagnes comme
dans le ring
justin trudeau le sous-estimer a
essoufflé ses adversaires cette jeunesse
pour lui reprocher aura été son atout le
plus grand je cerne tout simplement pas
prêt des adversaires qu'ils appelaient
juste comme s'il ne méritait pas son nom
de famille des gens souhaitaient se
débarrasser du gouvernement conservateur
de souhaiter le changement et cette
longue course qui devait l'achever selon
la stratégie des conservateurs lui a
donné tout le temps nécessaire pour
devenir l'homme du changement
à l'américaine quatre-vingt mille
bénévoles ont frappé à 11 millions de
portes à travers le canada
une bonne vieille recette politique mais
avec quelques nouveaux ingrédients mais
un application web qui fonctionne sur
les téléphones portables téléphones
intelligents mais également sur les
tablettes qui nous permettait d'aller de
porte en porte à la rencontre des
électeurs aient droit enregistrer
directement via l'interface mobile
les renseignements sur la personne are
you ready for children copie conforme de
la stratégie d'obama en 2008 une
campagne populaire multiplateforme
jeunes de nouveaux visages sur un vieux
parti
90% des candidats québécois étaient des
néophytes son père avant lui
justin trudeau fait craquer les foules
peut-on déjà parler de trudeau magnin
attendant de voir pour le moment on peut
parler de l'effet trudeau ici joyce
n'est plus radio canada l'envers